for a week Palestinians have been in the
dark their phone and internet
connections cut but some still find
their phones
useful I'm here at 7: a.m. as soon as
the sun rises this charging station
outside the emirati hospital is free a
Charged phone lasts about a day for now
we can only use it for lighting there's
no calls and no internet so we use it as
a light to see the roads we're walking
on and to light up the tents where we
live but for now we can't do much more
than that
a lack of communication is fueling
desperation and complicating the
delivery of food Aid and
Medicine the amount of Aid that's going
through the Rafa Crossing is not enough
I've been displaced for 60 days and I
still have not received a single food
parcel there are thousands others like
me hospitals are overwhelmed and
understaffed Naser Hospital in southern
Gaza is one of the few still functioning
but Israeli air strikes nearby could
force it to shut down and that would
force both patients and families to be
displaced yet again you've got patients
who are being operated on the floor
you've got patients who are sleeping on
the floor you have staff who are
sleeping on the floor um because they
prefer to sleep in the hospital than to
be able to take the to than to take the
risk going back and forth to their homes
which may or may not still
exist conditions are so unbearable one
doctor has amputated his daughter's leg
without
anesthesia in a video he explains a
family has been trapped inside the house
for 15 days with ongoing strikes the
risk of going to hospital is too
high where can we find mercy God please
have mercy on us where is the Muslim
World more than a 100 days of Israel's
war on Gaza has left Palestinian
families with nowhere to go and with
more than 24,000 people killed
confronting death has become a daily
part of life K lope oan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer